hey before you watch this podcast you
should know something on september 28th
the men shapiro show will be moving from
the daily water channel to be available
exclusively on my personal youtube
channel ben shapiro
you can get the link in the description
below i'm also making a lot of new
content that you can only find on my
channel so subscribe and ring the bell
to make sure you never miss out on a new
video
two la sheriff's department police
officers are gravely wounded in an
assassination attempt the nfl's virtue
signaling continues on matters of race
and california officials try to blame
global warming for their own
incompetence i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn you have a right to privacy
protected at expressvpn.com
ben well before we get to all of the
breaking news and there is plenty of
breaking news
let's talk about a simple fact if you're
not protecting your online data you are
not doing it right you need to protect
your online data why should you care
about encrypting your online data well
it's often easy for a hacker to bypass
wi-fi security and steal your
information which is why i use
expressvpn to stay secure
online and it's hard to know whether
your device your network is vulnerable
if you ever use a wi-fi in a public
place you're sending data over an open
network meaning no encryption
at all the best way to ensure your data
is encrypted and can't be read by
hackers check out expressvpn
the way that i do it's really easy just
download the expressvpn app on your
computer or smartphone and tap on button
to secure 100 of your network data and
then
you use the internet the way you
normally would expressvpn is incredibly
reliable it is the fastest vpn service
i have tried so if you want the best in
online security and privacy protection
head on over to expressvpn.com for three
extra months with a one year package
protect your internet today with the vpn
i trust to keep my data safe again
that's expressvpn.com
slash pen to get started expressvpn dot
com
slash ben go check them out right now
again expressvpn.com get three extra
months
free with a one year package go check
them out right now the people i trust
you should trust them
as well okay so over the weekend
we saw this horrific event in compton
which of course
is one of the most crime-ridden areas of
los angeles has been for decades
at this point in which a man walked up
to police to a police vehicle and
essentially attempted to murder two
police officers i mean
that's that's all this is i mean police
officers shot
point-blank range in the face and then
protesters tried to block the hospital
here is the story
via fox news protesters reportedly
shouting slogans like death to the
police
showed up to the la area hospital
treating two law enforcement officers
were ambushed and shot on saturday the
l.a county sheriff's
said to the protesters blocking the
entrance and exit of the hospital
emergency room yelling we hope they die
referring to two la sheriffs ambushed
today in compton do not block emergency
entries and exits to the hospital
people's lives are at stake when
ambulances can't get through okay here
is uh the basic rule here
if in fact you block an ambulance trying
to get into a hospital
because you are a human piece of debris
the ambulance should just run you over
okay if you you have like a second to
get out of the way if you if you are
purposefully putting yourself in front
of an ambulance that is attempting to
ship somebody who is injured and
requires life-saving medical attention
and you block the ambulance they should
just assume that you don't care about
your life because obviously you don't
you don't care about the person's life
inside of the ambulance you don't get to
block ambulances
a local faith leader who's at the
hospital told the kbc reporter the
protesters tried to then
break into the emergency room here's one
of the local faith leaders explaining
to abc 7 and kabc exactly what these
quote unquote protesters were saying as
they unloaded
the gurneys with the near corpses of two
la sheriff's deputies one of whom was a
31 year old mother and the other whom
was a 24 year old rookie
they were saying death to the police
killed killed the police
and they were using all type of
curse words and derogatory terms about
the police
just just provoking our police officers
unacceptable behavior because the
hospital should be a sanctuary where
where
you know that we we should leave
hospitals alone
okay well yes leave hospitals how about
this how about don't be a piece of crap
who celebrates the the attempted murder
of to police officers again the video
is absolutely insane it was taken by
security footage nearby
and you can see what appears to be a a
young i mean i assume this is a it looks
like a person who is minority but it's
kind of far away but you can see
sort of the color a person walks up to
the to the cop car
and takes two shots inside the car uh
and uh
shoots the jaw off of the female police
officer who then had to call
for medical attention the reaction by
people nearby
is absolutely insane and confirms a
simple fact
when you spend years promulgating the
lie that the police are systemically
racist and now to harm black people
and then the result is that people run
around
shooting cops taking pot shots at cops
resisting arrest
spray painting businesses with all cops
are bad acab
that is a predictable result of the
philosophy that the police are
systemically racist
there have been times in american
history where the police are in fact
systemically racist
and the way that you can tell they are
systemically racist is because you can
name the actual system of racism
you can point out the policy they are
implementing you can point out the
police practices that are in fact racist
but when you label something
systemically racist without naming the
practice
without naming the law without
explaining how the process produces the
racism
you just say that they're racists just
out there in the air
then anybody who's complicit with that
system is part of the racism and if
anybody who is part of the system is a
racist
well then all cops are bad by nature
that is the logical endpoint of a
philosophy that suggests that the police
are systemically racist without
requiring you to present any evidence
other than disparity because not all
disparity is discrimination
it is not well the predictable result of
that is people were literally
celebrating in the streets after two
officers were nearly murdered
in compton here is a video of one of
these uh pieces of crap
celebrating the celebrating the shooting
just aired the police out
they just aired the police off this the
only they go
they just got aired out good
they just bust on them that's crazy
they just got aired out somebody ran up
on the car and
bust on it right through the window in
the face and on
how how delightful how delightful what
what a wonderful culture we've created
in this country with regard to the
police officers
how how incredible how incredible and
there was video of protesters attempting
to enter the hospital grounds as we say
people attempting to break into the
hospital presumably prevent medical
attention from being performed on the
police officers who literally were just
sitting there
okay this was not even a case where the
police were in some sort of
confrontation with the criminal suspect
the police were literally just sitting
there in their car and they were
assassinated
right thank god they're not dead they
were in critical condition
i believe they're out of surgery at this
point but people are trying to break
into the hospital it's really really
charming
we are out here at saint francis
hospital where
two of america's most notorious gang
members
have been brought to uh we're going to
go up here
and uh just check on uh these murderers
right here
we're down here excuse me don't be
coming to visit someone no
we can't go visit nobody you can once we
confirm who it is but there's no
visitation
allowed anyway so you gotta go all right
y'all you see what's happening right
here right they got uh
these pigs out here okay literally this
guy's describing these uh these police
officers the pigs
they're all women of minority descent
right you can see it in the video these
are all it doesn't matter because
they understand from the philosophy of
all cops are bad
and the cops are systemically racist
once you join the cops
you are no longer black you're no longer
hispanic your
status as a person of color is now
called into question because after all
you have joined the system of oppression
saying over and over and over again that
a system is systemically racist again
without evidence without naming the
policy that needs to be changed
without explaining which officers are
bad or which people in charge
are the problem doing that implicates
everybody who is involved in that system
there is no excuse for this sort of
immoral behavior yet this has become
a democratic talking point it has this
doesn't mean that democrats are
responsible for people
going and shooting cops it doesn't i've
never been of the belief system
that if you say something that is not an
explicit call for violence and then
someone goes and performs violence this
is your fault
but if we are worried about raising the
temperature if we are worried about the
way
that words are used by people in order
to justify their actions
and if you are worried about a rising
tide of crime
and anti-police sentiment and then you
forward that sort of thing
then you are complicit in the broader
message and the broader message is a lie
it is bad and it does incentivize people
to violence so does that mean that joe
biden and
kamala harris are responsible for what
happened in compton no it doesn't mean
they're responsible for what happened in
compton any more than bernie sanders is
responsible for what happened
at the congressional baseball game or
any more than donald trump has been
blamed for what happened at the el paso
walmart right that's not the way this
works
if you haven't explicitly called for
violence you are not to blame but if you
do not bring down the temperature and if
you promulgate
lies that result in police officers
being targeted
maybe you ought to examine your own
ideology maybe you ought to examine your
own garbage philosophy because this is
garbage okay it is garbage to suggest
that the police broadly speaking across
the united states are systemically
racist
the evidence to that effect is zero it
is zero
there is no evidence that the police are
systemically racist
even if you want to make the claim that
the police are systemically too brutal
that they use excessive police force too
much that is a problem of police
brutality that would not necessarily be
a problem of racism
in fact in these major american cities
most major american cities that have a
heavy minority population the police
force
is plurality or majority minority but
that doesn't matter again once you are
implicated in the quote unquote system
then you're part of the racist system
this is this all is the the predictable
result of the imber max kennedy robin
deangelo
recap stokely carmichael recasting of
racism from
you have to identify a person who judges
people on the basis of race
or a policy that segregates people on
the basis of race or separates people or
treats people differently on the basis
of race
two a philosophy of racism that suggests
that any system that results in a
disparity of outcome
is itself racist and anybody complicit
in that system is a racist as well by
definition
the result of that is all cops are bad
you cannot philosophically separate
the police are systemically racist when
you won't name the racist policy or the
racist person
from all cops are bad because who's the
good person working within the racist
system
who's the good person it isn't the
minority police chiefs
who by the way have been resigning on
mass with a minority police chief in
seattle out we have the minority police
chief in dallas out we have the minority
police chief in rochester out
and this sort of stuff is happening all
across the country
and as we'll see people have been
willing to overlook the fact that the
police have been systemically
targeted across the country by blm they
have
and blm does not give a damn about the
facts they don't care about the facts of
any individual case they're not
interested
in alleviating police brutality they're
not they're interested in a narrative
the narrative is that all
all cops are bad that is the a that is
the blm slogan
okay to pretend anything else doesn't
mean everybody marching with blm knew
that was the slogan
but to separate off all cops are bad
from the blm messaging
is a lie and the way you can tell it's a
lie is because it doesn't matter what
the situation is
blm will provoke protests and riots
based on
any situation whatsoever involving a
police officer and a minority suspect
it doesn't matter what the circumstances
surrounding it are we'll talk about this
more
in just one second first let's cool down
for a second let's talk about
how you can make your house look better
so you're spending more time than ever
in your house
if you're on the west coast right now
you have to spend time in your house you
literally cannot go outside
the way that it works on the west coast
is because of covid you're not allowed
to go outdoors
to another place like you can't go to a
restaurant or museum or anything and
then
you can't go outside outside because the
air quality is terrible so you're in
your house all day long staring at those
ugly blinds well now that you're staring
at those ugly blinds now that i've told
you about that
maybe you want to replace those ugly
blinds with something much nicer
blinds.com they make it simple to shop
top quality
blinds shades interior shutters from
homes with easy online ordering and free
shipping
the experts at blinds.com understand
that window treatments are one of the
household items you just don't think
about
they can make a huge impact on the look
and feel of your home but you don't need
to do a full renovation by simply
changing what is on your windows you can
change the way light comes into your
home
and create a totally different feel go
to blinds.com just take a look at all
the options like faux wood blinds
cellular
cellular and roller shades even outdoor
shades if you're nervous about trying
them there really is no need to be
blinds.com has helped millions of
homeowners throughout the process
plus they guarantee the perfect fit
whether you do it yourself
or have the measure and install
everything for you go right now see how
much you can save at blinds.com we've
been using blinds.com for years we have
made our house look so much better
we had like some really old leftover
blinds when we bought our house and then
we replaced it with blinds.com really
has upgraded our feel
when you check out online don't forget
to tell them you heard about blinds.com
from the ben shapiro show rules and
restrictions may apply again check them
out blinds.com see how much
you can say when you go to blinds.com
and check out mention that you heard it
on the ben shapiro show okay so
the the situation in compton
unfortunately
is not a uh is not a an outlier
what we've seen according to abc news
okay remember this these are mainstream
media sources it's not coming from
right-wing sources as of july 22nd
okay so july 22nd several months ago
police officers
who had been killed this year surged 28
28 this according to abc news july 22nd
okay so now we're going back
approximately two full months
for having gotten a taste for public
service while in the us coast guard said
abc news jonathan troop joined the
police force looking for a career
he was passionate about after managing
delivery teams for amazon for nearly
five years his brother said
for 405 days the 32 year old troop
according to his brother
lived what he realized what his call was
his calling in life as a member of the
bothell washington police department
he became the 32nd u.s law enforcement
officer shot to death this year on july
13th
marking a 28 jump in felonious officer
deaths
over the same period in 2019 we have
seen a serious jump in the murder of
police officers over the course of the
year
particularly since the george floyd
protests began
as of september 11th 37 law enforcement
officers have been reportedly
feloniously killed
in 2020 that is an increase
a pretty significant increase 33
law enforcement officers were killed
total in uh
were non-feloniously killed in 2020 uh
or accidentally killed in 2020. this is
according to the fbi
eight were victims of an ambush
entrapment and premeditation two were a
victim of an unprovoked
attack uh so
just good stuff happening all across the
country in totality by the way more than
700 police officers were injured
in the george floyd protests across the
united states okay that was just as
of early june june 8th 2020 new york
post
more than 700 officers injured in george
floyd protests across the united states
which
probably means that thousands of
officers have now been injured across
the country
you can just see it in the headlines
right you can see in chicago july 21st
49 police officers
injured august 15th 2020 chicago 17
police officers injured
june 2nd 2020 l.a 20 police officers
injured july 26
2020 l.a four police officers injured
july 5th 2020 portland
several officers injured august 20th
2020 portland two officers were injured
after mortars were used july 15 2020.
three police officers were injured
serious head injuries the chief of the
department had broken fingers
august 9th 2020 news break reported more
than 100
officers were injured in protests okay
so we're talking about thousands of
police officers over the last couple of
months
who have been injured or or and and
a few dozen killed connected with the
rising crime that we've seen across the
country now not all those police
officers who were killed were killed as
a result
directly of blm or the riots but when
you lead to an upswing in crime
and when you continue to say over and
over and over the cops are racist
there is a predictable result to that
there is in fact a predictable result to
that
so how have democrats dealt with all of
this well they've continued to maintain
the narrative of course
so eric garcetti the la mayor he said
these attacks are abhorrent
you'll notice something in the
democratic response to this they'll say
the attacks are abhorrent at no point
will they say our police are not
systemically racist at no point will
they actually defend the cops
that's just not a thing they will bother
to do they're not going to bother
defending the police officers instead
they'll make vague statements about how
violence is bad now i'm old enough to
remember when this was considered
insufficient
i'm old enough to remember when it was
considered absolutely insufficient
to suggest that all violence was bad you
had to ideologically condemn
the philosophy that lay behind violence
this was in fact what joe biden said was
his leading cause in life after
charlottesville
but it turns out that if you're joe
biden you can simply elide the
philosophy of the people who are doing
the
the assassination attempts and the
widespread rioting and the looting
you can simply allied it simply by
pretending
that oh i covered it under the rubric of
all violence is bad
which is pretty astonishing stuff we're
gonna get to the democratic response to
this in just one second first
let's talk about how time consuming and
challenging hiring it can be
no when daily wire was small it was hard
enough now that daily wire is very large
it is very very difficult to find the
right person for our position because we
really need to do a lot of pre-selection
well what helps us with that
pre-selection
zip recruiter zip recruiter will send
your job to over 100 of the web's
leading job sites but they don't stop
there with their powerful matching
technology
zip recruiters scans thousands of
resumes to find people with the right
experience and then actively invite them
to apply to your job
zip recruiter makes hiring efficient and
effective with features like screening
questions to filter candidates and an
all-in-one dashboard where you can
review and rate your candidates
ziprecruiter is so effective that four
out of five employers who post unzip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the very first day if you're looking to
hire somebody or if you're looking to
get hired zip recruiter is indispensable
like let's say that you had a producer
let's call him nick for the sake of
argument who just randomly decided to
take two weeks off to go hunting wolves
in the woods in the middle of a wildfire
or something you might think
well you could probably find somebody
better to be a producer than a person
who goes and whittles in the woods in
the middle of a wildfire
and then you might check out
ziprecruiter right now try ziprecorder
for free by going to ziprecruiter.com
dailywire that is ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e
zip recruiter.com dailywire go check
them out right now ziprecruiter is
indeed
the smartest way to hire okay so how
have democrats responded to this latest
assassination attempt so eric garcetti
the la mayor right who's in charge of
the police department here's his
response
there's no place in civilized society
for anybody to draw an arm and
shoot our law enforcement officers that
put their lives on the line
and i won't ever let a couple voices
that not only
are uncalled for but it's important to
say something like that when we have two
deputies who are sheriff deputies in
grave condition this is
a country in which that sort of behavior
is unacceptable abhorrent
and we do pray that these folks will
recover and i hope that everybody
listening today will unify around that
okay well they should that's at least
better than what joe biden had to say
right notice he still won't say anything
about blm
but here is the joe biden kamala harris
statement you ready for this because
it's kind of long
jill and i were devastated to learn of
the cold-blooded shooting of two la
county deputies yesterday
as well as the horrific death of deputy
ryan hendricks a marine veteran and
police officer killed in the line of
duty in henderson county north carolina
these attacks are absolutely
unconscionable they bring only greater
violence and justice and grief to a
nation in desperate need of healing
oh only greater violence is it aha oh
that ah
yes i see brave officers who pin on the
shield carry a sacred responsibility
and make an extraordinary sacrifice just
as they owe it to the american people to
protect and serve with honor restraint
and accountability
americans owe it to them to lessen the
needless danger of their inherently
dangerous jobs act of lawlessness and
violence directed against police
officers are unacceptable outrageous and
entirely counterproductive to the
pursuit of greater peace and justice in
america right this is this is biden and
harris trying to prop up
the systemic police racism narrative at
the same time that they mourn the
shooting of these police officers
right it's making it it's more difficult
for us to effect change when people are
shooting police officers you see it's
not
it's bad that people shoot people and
it's also bad that you're
and that you're attempting to block our
ability to create change within police
departments
at no point here does joe biden or
kamala harris at no point will they
say we need to stop calling our police
systemically racist at no point will
they say that because that is their
narrative
instead the big problem here politically
speaking is not people who keep claiming
that the police
are a bunch of racists and that the
system is inherently racist and that
anybody who joins up with that system is
inherently racist
at no point will they stop making that
claim instead what they will do is they
will say yeah but if you shoot the cops
it makes it hard for us
to really make the argument about how
the police need systemic change
jill and i are keeping these deputies
and their loved ones in our hearts and
are praying for a full recovery for the
two la deputies
now fighting for their lives now this
sort of language of course is nothing
new
you know way back when during the obama
administration there were six dallas
police officers who were murdered by a
person associated with the black lives
matter
movement they were shot in cold blood in
dallas
and the president of the united states
also poopooed the association with black
lives matter
ideology of course because again the
narrative matters far more than the
actual consequences of the narrative
if you keep saying saying over and over
and over for the final time if you keep
saying over and over and over that
police departments across the country
are systemically racist
and then you can't name a policy that
you would change in fact you block any
attempt at political change
not only that but whenever there's an
incident involving the police you chalk
it up to police racism
even when it is obviously not police
racism
when you do all of that what you are
actively suggesting is that anyone who
works with the police is complicit in
systemic racism
and therefore bears guilt for the
systemically racist system
that is the claim that you are making
and in fact this is the claim that joe
biden
has repeatedly made right joe biden has
made that claim over and over and over
that doesn't mean that he's responsible
for cops getting shot
it does mean that he is responsible for
forwarding a movement
that does drive people toward an
anti-police perspective
the fringes of which will be violent
that is what that means
and by the way undercuts the policing in
areas that actually need policing what
we've seen in minneapolis
is that criminals are just not being
arrested you're gonna see the same thing
in la
in dc in new york and the predictable
increase in crime is going to fall
largely in minority high crime areas
this is backed by science by the way
roland fryer has done studies suggesting
that when there's a high-profile
police-involved shooting in any city
immediately following that there's a
tremendous rise in murder in those
cities
and those murders disproportionately
affect minority communities
okay the democrats know exactly what
they're doing at this point the
narrative matters more than human life
the narrative matters more than the
truth about the police
the narrative matters more than anything
because they can make political hay out
of it by saying over and over and over
that the system is racist
okay here is joe biden june 10th saying
absolutely there's systemic racism in
law enforcement
do you believe there is systemic racism
in law enforcement
absolutely but it's not just in law
enforcement it's across the board
it's in housing it's an education and
it's in everything we do
it's real it's genuine it's serious
look not all law enforcement officers
are racist my lord are some really
good good cops out there but the way in
which it works right now
you know we've seen too many examples of
it okay
that that is the most useless statement
in the world sure there are some good
cops but the system itself
is bad okay this is the precise polar
opposite
of the truth which is that there are
some good cop there's some bad cops
but the system overall is good if you
say the system overall it's good and
there's some bad cops that means we can
target the bad cops for removal
if there are some good cops but the
system overall is bad that means the
minute you pin on that shield
the minute that you put on the blue
uniform you are now part of the bad
system
okay this is the difference between
saying that there is an entire system
there's an entire nazi system out there
and there are a few good germans in that
nazi system
but overall the system's really bad and
saying well you know today
you know in germany there are probably
some neo-nazis out there but entirely
the german society is not not anywhere
that's the difference there's a polar
opposite difference in how you're
approaching the problem
and each system of the ideas have
consequences
ideas have consequences hey joe biden
has maintained this perspective for a
long time
he said same weekend june 10th he said
for too long black americans have lived
with a knee
on their neck a knee on their neck
and then he uh and then he talks about
systemic racism and then i mentioned
last week he put out a po
he put out an ad that begins by
suggesting that black americans
wake up every day believing they are in
danger of losing their lives due to
their skin color this was a biden ad put
out last week
and then you are shocked when the police
end up targeted
in minority communities you end up
shocked by this here is here's the biden
harris ad
why in this nation and black americans
wake up knowing that they can lose their
life
in the course of just living their life
part of the point of freedom is to be
free from brutality from injustice from
racism
now is the time for racial justice i
believe with every
fiber in my being black americans should
not wake up
in america believing they are in
existential danger of being murdered
because they're not
they are not they're not factually in
existential danger of being murdered in
the united states and certainly not by
the police
certainly not by the police okay but
once you back the narrative
you got to go all the way and that's
what blm does this is why blm is a
scurrilous movement
because blm does not care about the fact
blm is not interested
in distinguishing individual instances
of racism or even an identifying racist
policy
all they're interested in is tearing
down systems i'm going to show you proof
positive of this in one second first
let us talk about the fact that if you
got a lot of credit cards that you can't
let that debt continue to rack up you
just cannot do it
instead if you're a responsible person
you got to consolidate that credit card
debt and you got to get that rate down
so you can pay it off
this is why you need light stream light
streams fixed rate credit card
consolidation loans
start at 5.95 percent apr with autopay
and excellent credit
and get a loan from 5 000 to 100 000
bucks with absolutely no fees
the application is 100 online you can
even get your money as soon as the day
you apply
lightstream believes that people with
good credit deserve a great interest
rate and no fees and that's exactly
what they deliver people love
lightstream here's what one customer had
to say i heard about lightstream on this
podcast i was able to look on the
website get clear information
the application process was quick and
easy listen i've seen people's lives
destroyed
because they rack up the credit card
debt and then they cannot get out of it
because they fail to consolidate that
debt and lower the rate i mean once you
get 20 interest rates
you're dead right so instead you should
really check out lightstream
my listeners can save even more with an
additional interest rate discount when
you go to lightstream.com
shapiro that is
l-i-g-h-t-s-t-r-e-a-m.com
shapiro subject to credit approval rate
includes at 0.50 autopay discount terms
and conditions apply and offer subjects
you change that notice visit
lightstream.com
shapiro for more information that is
shapiro go check them out right now okay
so does blm actually
care about black lives overall the
answer is unfortunately no
because if they cared about black lives
what they would understand is that you
need the cops
in high crime areas to rid those areas
of crime but
blm doesn't care about black lives blm
doesn't care about cops blm cares about
narrative the narrative is america's
evil and america's police are evil
and this is why you see this continuous
press forward this is
like i got to be honest with you
conservatives are bewildered bewildered
and by the most rational people
should be bewildered by the attempt by
blm to lump
in every single police
civilian interaction as an element of
systemic racism no matter the
circumstance
it's insane it's insane like there are
instances
of police brutality and apparent racism
and if you want to look at apparent
races in the ahmedabary case
in which allegedly one of the suspects
said the n-word that would be a case of
apparent racism right i mean that's it
that's the case with some evidence to it
somebody has testified to that
okay the walter scott case in south
carolina in which a black man was shot
in the back by a police officer who
planted a gun
that is at the very least horrific
police brutality for which the guy is
serving a first degree murder charge
and maybe racism i'm not sure about the
racism aspect of the case because i
don't know the evidence of the case with
regard to racism
okay follow the evidence where it goes
and if the evidence supports a
particular charge of racism or brutality
then we should talk about the racism or
brutality in that particular charge
but instead you have to understand the
fact must be secondary to the narrative
in the case of blm
every case must be treated the same
because every evil
every evil by an individual is a result
of the racist system
it's an attempt to remove responsibility
from minority americans who are
committing crimes by suggesting the
system is indubitably and always
responsible
for those crimes and the police who go
to deal with those crimes
are indubitably part of a systemically
racist system no matter what they do
literally no matter what they do perfect
example last night in lancaster
pennsylvania
so last night in lancaster pennsylvania
there was a suspect
okay the suspect in lancaster
pennsylvania apparently was a hispanic
man
and he charged police officers with a
knife
here's the lancaster county district
attorney's office okay here's their
description they're going to play you
the tape okay because they have body cam
footage
the lancaster county district attorney's
office is investigating a police
involved shooting sunday afternoon that
resulted in the death of a man
lancaster city police responded to a
home in the 300 block of laurel street
about 4 15 pm
for a reported domestic disturbance on
scene a lancaster city police officer
fired at a 27 year old man who was armed
with a knife
the man identified as ricardo munoz was
killed and pronounced dead at the scene
the lancaster county da's office
investigates all officer-involved
shootings in lancaster county to
determine if force used by police was
justified in a crime occurred
the lancaster county detectives are
continuing to investigate
and d.a heather adams will make a final
determination on the use of force upon
completion of the investigation however
we would like to release some
information based on a preliminary
investigation
which included review of footage from
the firing officer's body camera
the footage shows that when the officer
gets in front of a residence in the 300
block of laurel street munoz immediately
engages from inside and runs toward the
officer
brandishing a knife above his head in
clear view in a threatening manner
the officer then fired no one else was
struck by the gunfire
here is the actual body cam footage
okay here comes the suspect he is
charging out the door the officer
attempts to retreat
he attempts to retreat and munoz is
coming at him with the knife over his
head
charging him charging him
as it turns out by the way this uh this
particular suspect
also happens to have been charged with
four counts of aggravated assault
just a couple of years ago in fact
on monday march 4th 2019 apparently
this guy was charged with stabbing
people
he was holding a knife apparently he saw
the officers and held the knife to his
own throat
the officers gave commands to him to
drop the knife he didn't comply he then
attempted to climb over a handrail
toward the front of a resident
residence and then they had to use a
taser on him
and then they took him into custody
apparently there were
there there were three adults who'd been
injured by this guy involved in stabbing
and slashing
and so this is called this is the
definition of a justified shooting right
this is the definition of a justified
police shooting
did it matter of course it didn't matter
there were riots in lancaster last night
protesting riots people smashing police
cars and the police
allowing it to happen by the way the
police
allowing these pathetic specimens of
humanity
to break apart smash windows break the
police car
okay the headlines by the media's
culpability in this is insane here is
the headline from from
nbcphiladelphia.com you ready for the
headline in this man shot and killed by
police in lancaster
wow conveying zero of the actual
relevant information how about
man charging officers while brandishing
a knife shot and killed in lancaster
oh but that would actually dissuade
people from rioting you mean you see
and so the the protesters gathered in
lancaster it was protests protests
gathered in lancaster
except for the fact that people started
smashing things and uh
and gathering to do property damage
never mind
the police were forced to use tear gas
the protesters
built uh barricades out of trash cans
and street signs
they damaged the post office so
apparently uh they are very against mail
and balloting
as well according to priscilla liguri
reporting for abc27
more than 100 people protested in the
city last night crews have spent the
morning cleaning up glass bottles and
bricks
scattered across the streets the
lancaster police station has a broken
door
and windows so
well done everybody here's the thing it
doesn't matter what the facts of the
case are
it doesn't matter what the facts of the
case are okay which is the definition
of people who don't care about truth if
you don't care about the facts of the
case you don't care about truth you just
don't
all you care about is the narrative one
of the
chief factors one of the chief people in
pushing narrative above facts
would be benjamin crump who's been the
attorney for nearly every
heavily covered race-based crime case of
the last
seven years in the united states going
all the way back to the trayvon martin
case in which he represented the trayvon
martin family
benjamin crump has an ugly habit of
simply lying about things that are
happening
it's really really bad okay because this
is picked up by the media and then
treated by people as the true narrative
on friday the family of george floyd via
benjamin crump
pushed back against accusations levied
against george floyd in court on friday
after lawyers claimed he had taken drugs
prior to his fatal encounter with
minneapolis police
in may defense attorneys for the four
officers charged in floyd's death
claimed he'd swallowed fentanyl before
his arrest
okay now they don't have to claim it
it's in the autopsy
in the every autopsy of george floyd
every single one has shown he had enough
fentanyl in him to kill a horse
he had a lot of fentanyl in him in fact
medically speaking
it is highly probable that george floyd
did not die from the compression
to his neck it is highly probable that
he died instead from the
overdose of fentanyl that caused excited
delirium which is an actual medical
condition in which basically
you kind of go crazy and then your heart
stops that is also likely what happened
in this case with daniel prude up in
rochester new york excited to learn is
an actual real medical condition when
you take very heavy doses of serious
drugs
it does happen there have been medical
articles about it i've read them on the
air that doesn't mean that excessive
force wasn't used with george floyd
it does mean it's gonna be very hard to
get a first or second degree murder
conviction
in that particular case okay but the
family of george floyd goes even further
they say he didn't even have drugs in
his system ben crump accused the defense
team of blaming the dead
a legal maneuver that flies in the face
of what we see with our own eyes on
video
here is uh here is what crump said the
only overdose that killed george floyd
was an overdose of excessive force and
racism by the minneapolis police
department
george was lucid cooperative obeyed
commands and had situational awareness
when he died
the world witnessed his asphyxiation on
video and now defense counsel is asking
us to disbelieve
our own eyes um
i'm sorry but no the video shows him not
being compliant with police officers the
video shows him
in fact bucking police officers asking
to be taken out of the car and put on
the ground
refusing to get in the car the video
shows that there were other people in
the car with him who complied with
police officers and were not even
arrested
the facts of the case do not matter they
do not matter
this is why it's almost a fool's errand
to engage in discussions of the facts of
the case because
for people on the blm side they actively
do not care about the facts of the case
they actively dislike facts of cases
facts of cases
cut against what they are trying to
promote which would actually be
solution-oriented because blm is not
solution-oriented blm is
problem-oriented because the only
solution they will stand for is tearing
down the entire system
okay benjamin again benjamin crump has
been doing this for a long time here's
what benjamin crump said about michael
brown michael brown there were two
independent state investigations
in the state of missouri with michael
brown there's a federal investigation by
the obama doj
all of them found that the shooting of
michael brown was justified that he
reached into the
officer's car a police officer's car
darren wilson reached into his car
fired a gun ran away from the cop turned
around charged the cop
before he was shot here's what benjamin
crump said about michael brown at the
time quote
that michael brown would be chased and
shot and then when he puts up his hands
that the police were supposed to protect
him repeatedly shoots him
okay here is here is
benjamin crump on jacob blake
jacob blake was quote breaking up a
fight between two women
he was not breaking up a fight between
two women he went to the house of a
woman
who had a previously alleged digital
rape with a child in the room
and then he resisted a rest and then he
went apparently for a knife in his car
on the floorboards of the driver's side
but the facts don't matter all that
matters is the narrative which is why we
have now seen repeated riots
over cases that are completely
uncontroversial as to the justifiability
of the shooting
we saw a complete riot in chicago based
on
an absolute lie as to something that
happened supposedly an unarmed young
black man was shot he was armed
can we we've seen this happen over and
over because the blm narrative is that
the police no matter what
no matter what it doesn't matter what
the antecedent is the conclusion is the
same in the sentence
blank happened thus the police are
systematically racist
okay you're gonna have to choose a side
here the democrats have chosen their
side
by the way choosing a side to be on the
side of police does not mean you're on
the side of bad police it doesn't mean
you're on their side of police brutality
it means that you're on the side
of the police who are defending you from
the bad guys every single day
that you judge each case independently
that you look at the circumstances of
the case but you got to choose you know
the side of the criminals you can be on
the side of the cops
the democrats have chosen they are on
the side of the criminals this is
perfectly obvious
as they continue to release rioters and
looters as they continue to try to bail
them out
13 members of the biden campaign bailed
out rioters in minneapolis
as they continue to claim over and over
that the police are systemically racist
but black lives matter is a wonderful
movement in favor of change
change they can't specify by the way and
a program they can't articulate beyond
abolishing the police
you get to choose to are you on the side
of the people
who cheer when cops get shot or are you
on the side of the cops
are you on the side of the people who
suggest that all police
are elements mere widgets in a
criminally racist system
or are you on the side of those police
officers who are serving and protecting
in the line of duty you have to choose
now
you have to choose we didn't have to
choose when we were talking about
specific problems with specific
solutions but when you name the police
as systemically racist and then the
police start getting shot
well now you're going to have to make
some choices aren't you you can either
side with
the jacob lakes of the world the alleged
rapists you can visit their families and
talk about how proud you are of them
or you can side with the cops who have
to capture these people and prevent them
from raping black women
by the way the alleged victim in that
case is a black woman you get to choose
this is your choice too in just a second
we're going to see how the media have
biased this choice because the media are
absolutely irresponsible in disgusting
disgusting ways we're going to get to
that
in just one second first let us talk
about the fact that it is not a great
time
for you to go to the auto parts store in
fact it's never a great time to go to
the auto parts store you know what's
great the internet i'm a big fan
internet great it allows you to buy
products that you need at a price you
want rockauto.com is no exception
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
prices possible rather than changing
prices based on what the market will
bear like airlines do
why would you spend up to twice as much
for the same parts rockauto.com is a
family business serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years
go to rockauto.com to shop for auto and
body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers best of all
prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers
why spend up to twice as much for the
same parts the rockauto.com catalog is
unique
remarkably easy to navigate quickly see
all the parts available for your vehicle
and choose the brands
specifications and prices you prefer
they've got amazing selection reliably
low prices and all the parts your car is
going to need
check them out at rockauto.com it just
doesn't make sense just waste time and
money by going to an auto parts store
and you can stay home
and get the lowest price with the exact
part go to rockauto.com right now see
all the parts available for your card
truck
right shapiro in there how did you hear
about his box so they know that we sent
you
okay we're going to get into the media's
willingness to
completely obscure the facts of these
particular cases to obscure
the choice that americans are being
asked to make in just one second
first if you watch this podcast on
youtube you should know on september
28th
it will be moving from the daily wire
channel to be available exclusively on
my
youtube channel the ben shapiro youtube
channel you get the link in the
description below
i'm also making a lot of new content you
can only find on my channel
and what we're doing for example all
sorts of new videos there's a
personality test that i did where you
can actually see how my personality
breaks down my reaction to batman
trailers and all the rest
like all my video basically is now
showing up on the ben shapiro youtube
channel so if you watch this over the
daily water youtube channel
right now pause what you're doing go to
the ben shapiro youtube channel and
click subscribe ring the bell to make
sure that you
never miss out on a new video also now
would be a great time to go pick up a
copy of my new book how to destroy
america in three easy steps
uh mark levin uh on the levin uh
tv well actually on mark levin's show uh
life liberty and levin over on fox news
he was featured again over the weekend
charged up the best seller charts again
go check it out it is worth the read
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
alright so the media of course have an
interest in lying about this if you look
at the headlines
over and over and over in every single
case they just lie now this goes all the
way back
frankly to trayvon martin when the media
decided that george zimmerman was a
white hispanic
and that he had not been injured in any
altercation with trayvon martin they
suggested he was lying about the
physical altercation that it turned out
he was not lying
the media unfortunately have a stake in
lying in nearly every one of these
circumstances they don't wait for the
facts to come out
they don't wait for it they just rush
forward with whatever narrative
is convenient for them well part of the
narrative is that the police are
systemically racist
another part of the narrative is that
the riots and the violence that we've
been seeing is non-ideological in nature
that what we've instead been watching is
basically
an even split between right-wing and
left-wing violence when it comes to this
major uptick in violence in america
cities the rioting and the looting that
has shut down
major american cities so one of the the
case that they've been pushing more than
any
case else is the kyle rittenhouse case
right written house was a 17 year old
who joined up with a militia to go and
quote unquote defend property in kenosha
wisconsin
okay now while he was there he was
apparently charged by
people wielding guns he uh he at one
point
shot a man in a parking lot after
somebody fired a gun in the air
and then he was charged by somebody he
shot one guy to death then he was
running away and he was being charged by
two other guys one of whom jumped on top
of him tried to
beat him up with a skateboard and
another guy who approached him with a
gun
and now you can see in this still photo
the man approaching him with a gun in
his right hand is a pistol that pistol
is pointed at kyle written house kyle
rittenhouse shoots him in the arm
the reason i bring this up is because i
mean here is a closer up photo you can
see the man gripping his arm
and you can see in his right hand is a
pistol okay now
here is the way that this was covered
the way that this was covered by the
media the media malfeasance here is so
astonishingly
open the the milwaukee journal sentinel
ran about the wounded man this headline
quote i walked away with my life that
night
wounded kenosha medic gage grassroots
tells his story
he's a wounded medic is he because the
way that normally medics approach people
is with brandishing a gun directly
pointed to them
that's normally how medics approach
people then he was featured on cnn
as a victim and he's wearing a hat that
says paramedic oh
okay he's wearing a hat that says
paramedic so just to be straight
the good the good guys according to the
media in these circumstances are people
who attempt to block hospitals
well ambulances with deathly wounded
officers are inside those are the people
associated with blm they're nice people
and also people who attempt to rush 17
year olds
with the who haven't ever have a rifle
right rush them with pistols
in an attempt to shoot them those are
the good guys the paramedic he's a
paramedic guys here was cnn covering
this over the weekend
i walked away with my life that night
two people didn't gage gross kroitz is
the only person to survive
of the three people shot during protest
in kenosha wisconsin
i think about the screams about the
gunshots
i think about everything all the time
i'm missing 90 of my bicep
i'm in constant pain like excruciating
pain pain that
just doesn't go away he he is the
he is he's just a paramedic guys you
just that video of him you know
the actual picture of him holding the
pistol that doesn't exist he was there
trying to provide medical attention with
a pistol that's typically what what
people do
okay all of this has the predictable
result of getting the american people to
believe things that are not true
so there's a fox news poll talking about
kenosha and portland
okay here's here's what the poll says in
general which better describes the
unrest happening in new york kenosha
portland and other places
protests or riots okay about half of
respondents say riots about 40
say protests when violence breaks out at
these events who do you think is more
often to blame
left-wing radicals or right-wing
radicals 39
left-wing radicals 33 percent right-wing
radicals
9 both 17
don't know well done media truly well
done
well done because you have accomplished
your goal which is to completely obscure
who is to blame for what's been
happening in america's major cities
really i'm impressed i'm impressed at
the ability of the media to push this
they've done an incredible job also
you know i was talking yesterday with a
friend about
exactly how this has happened how the
media has continued to maintain so much
power in promulgating false narratives
and there are a couple of factors one
you know the media have been
overwhelmingly left for for a long time
obviously and they're adept at getting
their message out but something
else has happened and that is i remember
back to 2004 during the election between
george w
bush and john kerry dan rather at the
very end of the election put out this
apparently falsified letter suggesting
that george w bush had gone awol right
it was this last minute surprise and it
turned out to backfire completely on the
media because the letter was made up
that george shelby bush had gone awol
back when he was in the air national
guard during vietnam
and i remember at the time there were
right-wing commentators who said that
because dan rather had been stopped
that the death of the old media was at
hand that the dominance the tsunami wave
effect of the old media had been broken
and i remember thinking that seems a
little bit like triumphalism
that the media still have enormous power
to push a narrative but the media did
something else
it's not just the media the left they
started using cultural mechanisms in
order to push
political messages so it was true that
the media diversified right daily wire
is an extraordinarily large site this
podcast this radio show are are very
very large
people listen to them right the right
wing does have its own ecosystem in
getting information out there
and the information is in fact out there
and that's good but
who the left had held in a band a bunch
of cultural institutions that they had
not fully activated
all of those cultural institutions are
now fully activated and you will be
cudgeled into submission
by all of these cultural institutions if
you don't buy the message that the news
media are promulgating
if you don't buy into the narrative that
all the violence that's happening has no
ideological cause
and that only violence that can be
attributable to right-wing supremacists
or white supremacists or armed
right-wing militias as joe biden likes
to call them
that only that violence can be pegged to
an ideology but violence
that has to do with congressional
baseball shooting
and then people claiming that they are
bernie sanders acolytes or dallas police
officers being murdered
by people who claim allegiance to blm or
police officers
being shot point blank in la
and blm protesters attempting to block
the hospital
the the non-ideological nature of all of
that kind of violence has been pushed by
the news media and if you don't believe
it if you don't believe it you don't
repeat it
then our cultural institutions will be
brought to bear
and that's why it matters what our
cultural institutions do
because that does shape how people think
it used to be that there was a certain
area of american life that was reserved
for politics and that's where we all
argued with each other we got very
passionate about politics
and then there were areas of american
life that were kind of reserved not for
politics
and that didn't mean people in those
areas couldn't speak freely they
absolutely could but
when you turned on a football game for
example what you watched typically was
football not social justice messaging
that cultured you into a particular
belief system
well the left has now activated every
element of its
fully armed and operational battle
system and that means every element
every cultural element from hollywood
which now is going to require that oscar
nominees have a certain level of
diversity implicit in either their plot
or their staffing so the nfl
which now insists that you mimic the
messages they want you to mimic
otherwise you're a racist
so over the weekend the entire nfl
decided to virtue signal
about black lives matter and to suggest
that america's systemically racist
the same america that gives a largely
minority league
incredible amounts of attention time
respect and money
is apparently systemically racist and
needs to be luxurious on their systemic
racism
every time they turn on a football game
and in fact if you don't go far enough
in pledging fealty to this if you try to
separate football in any way from the
politics you will be cudgelled
chris collinsworth pledged fealty to
this
and he got cancelled chris collinsworth
is the nbc broadcaster and he was
broadcasting the kansas city chiefs
houston texans kickoff
last week and he delivered a message
about the nfl social justice initiatives
and he talked about how he was in favor
of everything they were doing but he
added an unfortunate
line that got him canceled here was what
that sounded like
i feel like i have to start off by
saying i stand behind these players 100
100 what they're trying to do is create
positive change
in this country that frankly is long
long overdue so let's just get that out
of the way
and go call a football game okay it's
that last line let's get that out of the
way and go call a football game
piss people off piss people and also al
michaels who's sitting there and doesn't
say anything
he apparently is canceled as well see
here's the thing once you give in to the
woke culture
the the demands never stop and that's
what everybody on the cultural left
knows
right this is not merely a question of
political left it is now cultural left
every every aspect of american society
that the left controls will now be
weaponized in favor of narratives that
are
patently untrue like the police are
systemically racist and america puts
black people at existential threats
and america is a discriminatory horrible
place that is rooted in slavery and
bigotry
right these are the messages that will
be promulgated by every area
of american life so over the weekend as
i mentioned the nfl decided to go
full sjw shockingly the ratings were
down who could have believed it
okay here is according to the associated
press jason myers kicked off to start
the seahawks season opener against the
falcons
and the ball sailed through the end zone
for a touch back no one moved a step
instead
the players all dropped to one knee
after years of pleading with the nfl to
act against systemic racism
they were willing to wait another 10
seconds to make their point teams
opening this year in empty stadiums
knelt locked arms raised fists in
protest or stayed off the field entirely
for the star-spangled banner
and the black anthem lift every voice
and sing on sunday as the once reluctant
league
brought racial injustice to the
forefront on the nfl's first full slate
of games
so first of all the the idea there needs
to be a separate black national anthem
cuts directly against the idea that
we're supposed to be a unified polity
there's not a jewish national anthem
there's not a hispanic national anthem
there's one national anthem it's the
national anthem
if you want to say that this is an
important song for black americans
that's fine to call it a black national
anthem suggest that there is a black
nation that is separate from the united
states of america which is patent
which is just not true nor audit to be
true if you wish for us to be a common
polity
in atlanta the teams were armbands
honoring civil rights leader john lewis
and staged the most striking of the
day's gestures they barely flinched as
the opening kickoff landed beyond the
end line took a knee and remained there
for about 10 seconds before trotting off
the field
to resume the game it's a start falcon's
running bad
todd gurley said after the game are we
going to keep doing this you don't want
to make it a one-time thing just like
having a good time and then the rest of
the season you do nothing
the falcons also wore shirts with the
john lewis quote the vote is the most
powerful non-violent change engine you
have
in a democratic society and that's what
the falcons and seahawks did before the
game
everybody voted and said we're going to
come together as a unit so so basically
this is now a democratic party get out
the vote effort is is what this has
become
shocker because no systemic change is in
the offing right
remember the nba lebron james tried to
lead a walkout it failed
right he had to come back and their big
development what they got out of the
owners was we will now use our stadiums
we will now use our athletic arenas in
order to host voting this is a giant
democratic get out the vote effort no
actual policy changed well done
everybody
well fans were absent everywhere except
jacksonville because of the coronavirus
pandemic
the minneapolis the minnesota vikings
hosted the family of george floyd
who died in may in a videotaped killing
that sparked national protests over
police brutality against black people
vikings players locked arms in the end
zone about a half hour before their game
against green bay for lift every voice
which was played before each game in
week one
along with the national anthem as part
of the nfl's social awakening
at least six vikings knelt during the
star-spangled banner something coach
mike zimmer had opposed
about 10 of george floyd's relatives
were shown on the stadium video board
from their perch in the upper concourse
near the jalhorn the symbol from norse
mythology which gave the vikings their
name has been sounded before every game
since 2007 on sunday the team said to
remain silent
to call attention to these silenced
voices and collectively work toward a
better more just society which voices
have been
silenced exactly i've been noticing 15
to 26 million
protesters across the country which
voices have been silenced exactly
the packers remained in their locker
room for both songs following the lead
of the miami dolphins
the jacksonville jaguars buffalo bills
new york jets and arizona cardinals also
remained in their locker rooms
for both songs colts coach frank
dropped 20 his players noticed frank is
the leader of the team he's the one who
says you know it starts with me
indianapolis linebacker darius leonard
said
that definitely means a lot and that's
why we stand behind coach frank he
stands behind us
we all stand together
so all of the auspices of
social justice will be brought to bear
via our cultural institutions now the
hilarious part of all of this of course
is that it's never going to be enough
once you bend the knee
then joffrey come the social justice
warrior movement the woke culture
is not a forgiving culture in which you
earn your way into paradise
the woke culture is king joffrey and
once you bend the knee
the head is the next thing to fall okay
once you bend the knee as a corporate
entity
there will be no end to the demands case
in point
former san francisco 49ers quarterback
colin kaepernick blasted the nfl
on the league's opening on sunday
calling the nfl's new social justice
focus propaganda
okay fair point colin kaepernick correct
it was also propaganda when he did it
but now he says the nfl
is trying to cover up for its own
continued racism see the thing is once
you made
colin kaepernick your moral adjudicator
you're in serious trouble nfl
so why exactly is it propaganda because
eric reid one of the first players to
support cop kaepernick's anti-racism
kneeling protest
remains unsigned after being let go by
the carolina panthers back in march
the nfl announced earlier this year that
in the wake of massive anti-racism and
anti-police brutality protests that took
place in nearly every major city
they would set a weekly social justice
priority embrace blm slogans and
encourage players to take part in
demonstrations service projects and
social justice focused
initiatives according to emily's
inaudible wire
none of that matters said kaepernick on
sunday if reid remains blacklisted
while the nfl runs propaganda about how
they care about black life they are
still actively blackballing eric reed
for fighting for the black community
eric set two franchise records last year
and is one of the best defensive players
in the game
so now they're gonna have to appoint
colin kaepernick the gm of every team
remember ea sports already made him a
starting quarterback with franchise
potential
so in their video game madden 21. now
every team should just make colin
kaepernick the actual gm right i mean
he's going to hire eric reid
he played and started all 16 games for
the carolina panthers last season he
recorded 130 tackles four sacks he
joined the panthers a few weeks into the
2018 season he recorded 71 tackles and
an interception
in that season according to according to
colin kaepernick
so number one let me just put this out
there if i were an nfl owner i would
hire colin kaepernick immediately
immediately and i'd make him my starting
quarterback and i would say something
very simple
which is the entire world of media
sports
has told us that colin kaepernick is the
most talented player ever to play the
game
so i'm making him my starting
quarterback i don't care who else i have
on the team
i'm making my starting quarterback and i
assume he will justify those
expectations
and if he gets sacked every down i'm
leaving him in first of all you want to
restore the ratings of the nfl do it
second of all we all know that colin
kaepernick is not playing because colin
kaepernick doesn't actually want to play
but if i were an nfl owner i am full
scale in favor of colin kaepernick being
able to speak on whatever topic he wants
to speak out about and then get sacked
because he can't make a secondary read
and as an owner i'd put my money where
my mouth is plus my ratings would
actually spike pretty dramatically
and the underlying logic to all of this
in the end whether it is cultural
intimidation
via your sporting events or whether it
is
these protests in the streets or whether
it is media that wishes to call you a
racist if you disagree
with their failure to even bother to
report facts
the underlying element here the
underlying idea and and it's employers
too i mean i can't tell you how many
notes i get on a daily basis from people
who feel intimidated in their workplace
and are deeply afraid to speak out
because they're afraid that they will be
fired by their employer for having the
temerity to question whether america is
systemically racist and whether police
are systematically evil
the underlying idea here is very obvious
and that is
that the that is that unless you give
democrats power all of this continues
that you have to surrender surrender is
the only option
that is the underlying logic here some
people are being pretty clear about this
shadi hamid
has a piece over at the atlantic today
called the democrats may not be able to
concede
if trump wins especially after losing
the popular vote the left may draw the
wrong conclusions
according to shadi hamid he says a loss
by joe biden under these circumstances
is the worst case
not because trump will destroy america
he can't but because it is the social
outcome
most likely to undermine faith in
democracy resulting in more of the
unrest and street battles that cities
including portland oregon and seattle
have seen in recent months
for this reason strictly law and order
republicans who have responded in dismay
to scenes of rioting and looting
have an interest in biden winning even
if they could never bring themselves to
vote for him
in presidential elections once as a
fluke twice as a pattern i struggle to
imagine how beyond utter shock millions
of democrats will process a trump
victory
a loss for biden at a time when
dissolution is already dangerously high
means that things will get really ugly
if democrats can't beat a candidate as
unpopular as trump during a devastating
pandemic
and a massive national economic
contraction are they even capable of
winning presidential elections anymore
democracy after all is supposed to
self-correct after mistakes particularly
mistakes as egregious as electing
donald trump donald trump
this time it would be worse than in
2016.
because biden's poll numbers this year
have been mostly higher than clinton
were in 2016 a trump victory will be
even harder for the left to absorb
until democrats started panicking
recently overconfidence had set in
the polls offered good reason to think a
trump victory was drifting out of reach
if trump manages to win he will likely
do so despite losing the popular vote
liberals have convinced themselves that
republicans are in one way or another
cheating and democrats have a right to
be nervous says shady hamid over the
atlantic
he says that we may not be uh that we
may on the be on the border of
a revolution he says a certain kind of
cognitive
dissonance the gap between what is and
what should be can fuel revolutionary
sentiment and not in just a fluffy
radical chic
kind of way in such situations acting
outside
the political process including through
non-peaceful means becomes more
attractive
not necessarily out of hope but out of
despair
so in other words the right should cave
to democrats and elect democrats so that
leftists don't riot blackmail is not an
electoral strategy nor should it be
it is not an electoral strategy nor
should it be
okay the fact that the that and a writer
for the atlantic is now openly
acknowledging
what we all know to be the case which is
that the democrats have basically made
their case
that they are going to allow riots to
continue in america's major cities
and justify every bad thing that happens
on the basis that america is
systemically racist unless you elect
them
i mean that is joe biden's proposal is
it not he keeps saying it over and over
take him at face value joe biden keeps
saying over and over and over again
that unless you elect him america's
wounds will not be healed
it will remain open and the unrest will
continue
now they're saying the quiet part out
loud if you fall victim to that
blackmail if you decide to humor the
blackmail just understand
blackmailers never stop blackmailing
they just understand they've got you by
the shorthairs and they continue
to draw you in so
americans do not bend the knee to
movements that don't care about truth or
decency
do not bend the knee to movements that
suggest that the only alternative to
giving them power
is violence in the street don't do it
pick a side all right we'll be back here
later today with two additional hours of
content we didn't have a chance even to
get to covid or
california wildfires we'll get to that a
little bit later on in the program in
the meantime have an excellent day i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wydowski our
associate producer is nick chien
the show is edited by adam syavets audio
mix by mike caromina hair and makeup is
by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
i go away for one week one week
and i come back to pedo movies on
hollywood's biggest platform
and the town literally on fire ash
covering my front steps
we have got a lot to catch up on before
the well-deserved fire and brimstone
takes us all out check it out on the
michael knowles show